natural law is the idea that the laws of
our society should mirror human nature a
lot of our institutions our governments
our markets and things are based on this
notion of natural law that came up in
the 1700s and the natural law they're
referring to is that humans are
basically competing all the time in
fighting but that's not who I am and I
don't think that's who you are either
my inspiration is a whole series of
situations that didn't work very well
schools that didn't work very well
organizations that didn't work very well
and disappointment with government in
general and I just think there has to be
a better way it was clear that the
digital ecology the digital society
wasn't turning out the way people hoped
you should have the same rights and
obligations in your digital self as you
have in your physical self you should
control information about you who gets
it and what they do with it
you shouldn't stand naked in the digital
you know spotlight in order to be able
to get something done and so I began
thinking about this and realized that
the problem was is that the basic model
of what is a human was wrong well as an
anthropologist that are studying early
human society and what they find doesn't
match with natural law of the 1700s now
we know that early humans were actually
very egalitarian human nature is to do
trading and interaction with trusted
others we should make the social
networks that we're building mirror the
way humans like to operate in how we
operate best and it's not open
competition it's through trusted
networks if you can trust people and you
know that this is this is a safe
relationship because it has all these
other relationships turns out to be more
optimal so the core thing and the trust
network is that you own your data is
private and you only share it when
you're gonna get something back for at
our NGO ID cube we've actually built the
software and built the legal contracts
to do this currently the only people
that have these trust networks are the
big guys the banks the hospital is
things like that and what we're doing is
making them available to the little guy
but what that's going to do is it means
the big guys are not going to have as
much power as they used to have so what
I'm trying to do is think about how
could we make a new digital society that
really works for humans you know that's
fair that's safe that's efficient the
scales it's inclusive so how feasible is
that in time scale and the answer is it
could happen very quickly you have the
banks the old institutions tottering
along based on their ownership of the
data and when you get a competitor that
gives people back their data but it's
just as efficient it could happen
almost overnight